I don't always pay no worse Harrison
wells work in quantum theory is
lightyears ahead of anything they're
doing at CERN you're doing that thing
where you're not speaking English you
know it's more than just Karma it's the
principle of infinite consequence at
work in our lives it's always expanding
creating positive sums on an infinite
basis everything the human race has ever
learned until this moment that is
everything we could learn from the
particle accelerator it's a whole new
way of looking at physics it will
literally change the way that we think
about everything you've gotta get
yourself a girlfriend
iris you wait it's pregnant women who
glow brides blush have we met
no no I'm a complete and total stranger
hi dad hi dawn wait there are two in
there we're having twins
boilers we're gonna need more diapers
coincidence I think not hey everybody so
I've been getting a lot of requests to
do a bigger video for Dawn Alan
iris West speedster so there are two
really big things but they are connected
by the end of the season although taken
separately there have been a couple big
news announcements recently they
confirmed that iris West would be
wearing a version of the flash costume
so I'll explain what that's all about
but it's all part of this bigger mystery
with the new girl that's writing the
same speedforce symbols that Barry wrote
when he came out of the Speed Force
so coincidence I think not I was so
happy that I remembered to include that
Incredibles clip because it's so
appropriate for what's going on in the
flash TV show right now but there is a
new round of the flash ring giveaway
I'll explain at the end of the video if
you are new be sure to subscribe to get
everything because we do have a ton of
stuff coming up this season but let's
start with the dawn Allen character
first I'll do iris West speedster at the
end of the video so dawn Allen is just
the person that we're calling her she
seems to be Barry's daughter that's the
important takeaway is that she's
connected to Barry because of a couple
important music cues when she appears on
screen in some of the things that she's
actually wearing on her body in this
scene here there were some funny ticks
that she had during her first meeting
with Barry total stranger just
that she was not a stranger she knew
exactly who Barry was in was just so
happy to see him like it was the best
thing that she'd ever done her entire
life but now we have a little more
context because like they say Allen
always pays BAM she slaps her hand down
on the table but she's also wearing a
couple rings
zoom enhanced one of these actually
looks kind of like the flash ring
although I can't quite make it out a
hundred percent so I won't say like a
hundred percent this is definitely the
flash ring she's wearing but it looks
like the flash ring and what is that
choker that she's wearing around her
neck - that's the exact same choker that
Caitlin was wearing in the first episode
maybe she got that from one of the other
members of team flash in the future I
think we can all agree that she's from
the future it's just a question of when
she's from because of the Speed Force
symbols a lot of people are thinking now
that that's actually interlac which is a
language that comes from the Legion of
super-heroes comic books this is what
interlac and the comic books looks like
now the symbols have actually appeared
on Supergirl because they're doing
Legion of super-heroes the symbols
correspond to the different members of
the Legion so a lot of people early on
thought that this might be a legion
character but really I think that she's
just specific to what's going on in the
flash I don't think that she has
anything to do with what's going on on
Supergirl
that's why I don't think that she's a
member of the Legion I think whatever we
see her do in the short term it's all in
surface of a flash family reveal because
there's a big thing on the show this
season about women being pregnant
getting powers from pregnancy so it all
seems to point to the fact that iris is
going to get pregnant and this will be
one of their children if not the only
child there are a lot of questions about
tornado twins because they have twins in
the comics so if this is gonna be dawn
Allen then where's her twin brother do
end on Allen is he somewhere back in the
future is there some bad thing in the
future that she's coming back into the
past to change or are they doing
something totally different with the
idea and using her is more of a Bart
Allen character because Bart didn't have
any twins now there was an evil clone of
him that was called inertia but he was a
clone he wasn't his brother or anything
like that but the reason why I think
it's his daughter not his granddaughter
even if they do use her as more of a
Bart Allen is is because it'd be more
meaningful for Barry if you're not a big
comic book reader
Barry died during crisis on Infinite
Earths before his children were born so
he never got to meet them so his
daughter and his son grew up without
ever having known him so is this really
tragic story because most of the people
that got to interact with the tornado
twins were during the Wally West air in
the comics when people still thought
that Barry was dead but don't worry too
much about comic book plot because I'm
expecting the TV show to do their own
version of it obviously this is all
connected to the thinker's plot which
was something that happened during the
Wally West era so they're mixing and
matching a lot of things they will just
have to follow the clues for Easter eggs
but you hear things like them using the
same scientist soundtrack whenever she's
on screen they used when Barry's on
screen getting all excited
[Music]
they talked the same way and it looks
like she's wearing the flash ring she
could have only gotten that from a
couple different people depending on
where she is in the timeline and then
there's the question of whether or not
she's an actual speedster but a lot of
you been asking why I've been talking
about pregnant women getting powers from
their pregnancy in next week's episode
Cecile is supposed to temporarily get
mind-reading powers because of her
pregnancy implying that her baby might
also be a metahuman or there's some
crazy Dark Matter stuff going on that
ties into what the thinker is doing but
a lot of you when I started talking
about that are like why would they just
randomly give women powers because of
their pregnancy is it intended to be
just a funny one-off thing no the reason
why they're giving Cecile powers because
of her pregnancy is to tee up this iris
West speedster story that they're doing
and I think it's episode 16 so at this
point The CW has officially confirmed
like they announced it on Twitter and
social all over the place
that iris West would be temporarily be
getting flash powers and why would that
happen maybe because she's pregnant so
they did say it'd be temporary obviously
you eventually have the baby so the
powers go away or the baby just gets to
a certain stage of development in the
powers don't transfer to you either way
crazy Speed Force baby pregnancy powers
will turn her into the TV show's version
of excess because that's the costume
she's wearing so a lot of people that
think that this character might be
excess I think the fact that iris West
is wearing a version of the excess
costume throws water on her being a
legion character so just more evidence
that it's someone a little closer to
home than the legion of super-heroes but
hopefully that explains a little bit
about all the evidence that stacked up
that this is Barry his daughter she's
almost exactly like Barry she acts like
him talks like him and if they're
pushing flash family this season like
why would I risk get pregnant if they
didn't want them to have a flash family
literal flash family although when you
say flash family the actual term applies
to all speedsters that aren't evil like
Jay Garrick Jessie quick they're flash
family so a lot of this is all in
service of season 5 stuff so they can do
flash family in season 5 like we can get
to Bart Allen we can get to their
children we don't know exactly how fast
they're pushing that stuff because I
don't know how many
episodes this actress is going to be in
but I have a feeling that she's not
gonna be in every single episode she'll
just pop up every once in a while and
continue to tease out more clues and
then by the time we get to the last
couple of episodes she'll come back and
you'll learn exactly who she is like
they will leave no room for guessing but
at this point I don't feel like we need
that many more clues I feel like they've
given us everything that we need and it
really just goes back to those music
cues as well as the way that she talks
and acts but for those of you asking
about iris West speedster and why she'd
be wearing this version of the costume
and not the red looking one from the
comics I think that's just because they
want to give everybody a different color
palette on-screen that's probably the
biggest reason why you haven't seen wall
to get a new version of the suit because
when everyone's running around on screen
together and it gets really jumbled up
and crazy action scenes they want it to
be this rainbow of colors like Green
Lantern spectrum of color kind of
situation where they'll probably tease
out next is is what's going on with
these Speed Force symbols and how she's
connected to it because episode 10 after
we came back from the break iris is like
maybe we should look into those symbols
maybe they can teach us something and
nobody on Team flash has referenced that
since then and we're getting ready for
episode 12 so at some point in the next
couple of episodes Cisco and someone
else is gonna have to start decoding
more of those symbols and then they'll
start to figure out Barry got a look at
the future when he was in the Speed
Force existing beyond space time and
then they'll tie it back to this person
here how she's connected to it so one
thing at a time like the next thing
we'll get will probably be more about
the symbols but let me know in the
comments who do you think this person is
given all the evidence that we've seen
so far remember to leave some room for
left turns because they could be doing
some sort of Bart Allen twist with
Barry's daughter like she could be
Barry's daughter but they could be
turning her into a version of Bart Allen
even though her name would be a little
bit different it's really just important
what her name is because then we'll know
whether or not she has a twin brother
and why he's not here too but like I
said there's a new round of that flash
ring giveaway congratulations to the
winner from my last arrow video Mac
Taylor please private message me so I
can get your contact details there was a
new round on this video I'll name a
winner when I post new DC but click here
to rewatch that brand new flash trailer
and click here for the Black Panther
Super Bowl trailer in new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see
guys tonight